[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques
et sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation
l'organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord l'otan a été créée en 1949 pour
défendre l'europe compte une agression
soviétique par une action coordonnée des
pays européens avec les états unis qui
en seraient les chefs compte tenu de
leur puissance militaire estime l'un
l'hégémonie américaine trop importante
le général de gaulle a quitté l'otan en
1966 pour retrouver son indépendance
tout en restant partenaires et en 2009
le président sarkozy à réintégrer la
france dans l'organisation
après la chute du mur de berlin en 1999
et en 2004 les pays du nord faisant
anciennement partie du bloc de l'est ont
rallié l'union européenne et surtout le
temps pour les états du groupe devise
grade ou les pays baltes
seule l'alliance milité avec les
américains pouvaient leur éviter une
agression rue à la même époque
l'otan s'est mobilisée sur les balkans
les allemands ayant favorisé
l'indépendance de la croatie d'autres
parties de la yougoslavie comme la
bosnie en 92 puis le kosovo en 99 ont
voulu devenir indépendant au détriment
de la serbie est en contradiction avec
le dogme occidentale des frontières
intangibles
cette remise en cause des frontières
historiques
proposé par les états unis est validée
par les membres européens de
l'organisation a été au coeur de
l'action de l'otan dans l'ancienne
yougoslavie
près les attentats du 11 septembre
le président bush a décidé de faire la
guerre en afghanistan contre ben laden
que le chef taliban mollah omar refusait
de livrer et ce fut le début de
l'opération enduring freedom en 2002
sous la pression américaine et un mandat
de l'onu les pays de l'otan sont sortis
de leur cadre géographique l'europe pour
s'engager dans ce pays loin de l'europe
dans la composante militaire de la
coalition qui était la force
internationale d'assistance à la
sécurité
cet ensemble qui comptait 61 1960
soldats en 2009 et monte à 131
1983 en 2011 elle a été remplacée en
2015 par michane réseau le dessus porte
qui voulait faire monter en puissance
une armée afghane de 300 milles la
france a compté sur le terrain près de
4000 militaires en 2010 et s'est retiré
de l'opérationnel en 2014 elle a
souffert de lourdes pertes puisque 90
soldats français ont été tués dont dix
lors de l'embuscade d'uzbin et cinq dans
un attentat kapisa mais nous avons eu
également 700 blessés ce qui n'est pas
rien dès le début de son mandat le
président trump avait annoncé sa volonté
d'arrêter les guerres extérieures et de
faire revenir les soldats obéi pour lui
il ne fallait pas perdre son temps et
son argent en afghanistan en europe et
ailleurs il fallait se concentrer sur le
véritable ennemi économiques et
militaires qui étaient la chine est loin
derrière la russe
c'est pourquoi son équipe a mené au
qatar des négociations avec les talibans
pour organiser la transmission du
pouvoir à kaboul et permettre leur
retrait unilatéral du pays
parallèlement il sortirait d'irak ne
gardait ses forces spéciales en syrie
comprennent des puits de pétrole
exploité par les kurdes avec une
compagnie pétrolière américaine et
négocier nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
parler lors d'une autre émission les
accords d'abraham avec les principaux
pays du golfe persique et israël il
s'agit d'un changement stratégique
majeur par rapport aux principes ayant
justifié les guerres américaines des 30
dernières années qui a été confirmée
récemment par le président biden les
états unis
ne veulent plus faire la guerre pour des
motifs humanitaires
ou pour implanter la démocratie ils ne
veulent la faire que pour défendre leurs
propres intérêts la question était de
savoir si cette évolution aurait l'aval
du complexe militaro-industriel
américain qu'on appelle le dip state
galets perdre un gros chiffre d'affaires
avec l'arrêt toutes ces guerres on
afghanistan par exemple
les usa ont dépensé près de 2200
milliards de dollars durant les vingt
ans de guerre l'absence de réactions et
de commentaires sur le retrait afghan a
apporté la réponse tous sont d'accord la
nécessité de monter en puissance face à
la chine dont le budget militaire
rappelons le sera de 276 milliards de
dollars cette année va permettre de
compenser largement ses pertes locales
dans le cadre d'un budget militaire
américain qui s'approche aujourd'hui des
800 milliards de dollars
et va augmenter
pour maintenir un net avantage
stratégique en commençant par les navy
face à l'évolution rapide de la marine
chinoise
ainsi les sous marins nucléaires
australiens seront construits
principalement aux usa
alors que les français allaient
construire leurs sous marins classiques
sur place ce qui évidemment ne donne pas
les mêmes résultats financiers
contrairement aux convictions de
nombreux dirigeants européens
qui le voyaient comme un anti trump
souvenez-vous le président baydan soit
le plein internationale à continuer dans
la ligne de son prédécesseur
en désignant la chine comme l'ennemi
majeur pour les décennies à venir étant
un politique très expérimentée il veut
éviter d'avoir à mener une guerre sur
deux fronts c'est pourquoi il a commencé
à genève récemment à trouver un terrain
d'entente avec le président poutine sur
différents points de friction pour
essayer de le découper de la chine
l'accord sur le fonctionnement du nord
stream 2 lui a permis de sécuriser ses
liens prioritaire avec la première
puissance européenne l'allemagne qui va
devenir le hub du gaz en europe et en
même temps de faire un signe fort vers
le président russe en facilitant ses
exportations vers l'europe dans les mois
à venir y va d'ailleurs être très
intéressant de voir au delà des
gesticulations
l'évolution de la position américaine
réel sur l'ukraine pays que connaît très
bien le président by dane et sa famille
en afghanistan des accords de doha signé
le 29 février 2020 menée sans la
participation des alliés de l'otan qui
ont été placés devant le fait accompli
avait défini le processus de
désengagement américain et de prise du
pouvoir par les talibans lors du début
du retrait unilatéral des alliés en mai
2021 deux éléments ont perturbé le
planning qui avait été fait à d'or
'l'annonce la date précise du 31 août
comme celle du retrait définitif de tous
les américains a obligé les talibans à
être dans la capitale à cette date pour
prendre réellement la totalité du
pouvoir en défi des chefs de guerre
régionaux et des sceaux occidentaux
souvenez vous ceci les amener à faire
une guerre éclair en prenant une
douzaine de villes clés en quelques
jours il faut dire que les 80 à 100
milles talibans ont été aidées dans leur
action par le pakistan qui leur aurait
fourni 20 mille combattants de plus et
par la libération de 5000 combattants
emprisonnés dans le pays le deuxième
point a été l'effondrement pourtant
prévisible de l'armée afghane mal payés
mal formés
elle ne voulait pas se battre et perdre
la vie alors que tout était perdu
d'autant qu'ils ont su très vite que la
quasi totalité des dirigeants
avaient quitté le pays en emportant les
caisses de l'état une chose est sûre le
retrait des uns et la désertion des
autres a permis aux talibans de
récupérer une quantité de matériel
militaire considérable même si le départ
des américains c'est fait quand ils
l'ont voulu et qu'ils avaient fixé la
date le passage du pouvoir aux talibans
après vingt ans de guerre est une
défaite pour l'ensemble des occidentaux
des américains ont décidé seul de venir
puis de partir de ce pays mais entre
temps il y avait fait venir leurs alliés
le bilan est désastreux gare
l'afghanistan d'aujourd'hui est un pays
très pauvre avec 90 % de sa population
vivent avec moins de deux dollars par
jour qui a énormément souffert de la
guerre ayant eu de nombreuses victimes
civiles et c'est sans doute pourquoi
plus de 80 pour cent des afghans sont
pour les talibans si l'on en croit un
sondage qui a été publié récemment un
d'une organisation internationale
monsieur le drian d'autres ministres mal
informée par ses services espérait que
le gouvernement serait inclusif pour
protéger les afghans occidentalisé il
n'était pas le seul puisque ministre
iranien mohammed jawad zarif
espérer la même chose mais lui pour
protéger les asa nous en sommes loin car
ce gouvernement comme vous l'avez vue
est composée exclusivement de talibans
et quatre d'entre eux sont passés par
guantanamo
dont faut bien le dire les pratiques ne
développe pas un amour immodéré pour
l'occident on ne peut donc s'attendre à
une évolution libérale des esprits mais
il est vrai que les talibans ont appris
de leurs erreurs en 2001 lorsqu'il
dirigeait le pays il avait interdit la
culture du pavot ce qui avait ruiné les
paysans les avait poussés dans les bras
des opposants cette fois ci ils ont
annoncé qu il les laisserait produire
tout en contrôlant son commerce il faut
dire que pendant l'occupation
occidentale
l'afghanistan est devenu le premier
producteur mondial
avec 2300 tonnes d'opium et 90% de
l'héroïne soit 2 milliards de dollars
ceci représente 10 % du pib du produit
intérieur brut et concernent directement
ou indirectement
20% de la population des talibans qui
ont trouvé les caisses de l'état vides
vont avoir besoin de cet argent pour
investir
mais ceci ne va pas les empêcher de
chercher à être bien vu du fmi et des
bailleurs de fonds pour pouvoir leur
gérer leur pays à leur manière
d'autant qu'ils n'ont aucune envie de
créer des problèmes ailleurs
contrairement à une image colporté dans
nos pays qui est bon et il souvent
dépassés par l'événement le départ
programmé des militaires et des civils
américains a été une réussite
compte tenu des conditions la base de
bagram la plus grande base américaine en
afghanistan a été abandonnée en un week
end et sur l'aéroport de kaboul la
programmation logistique et la
coopération entre les talibans qui
contrôlaient les voies d'accès et les
américains qui étaient à l'intérieur a
permis de réaliser le plus gros pont
aérien de l'histoire avec plus de 350
mille personnes transportées au qatar à
doha dans un délai très court et pour
montrer que symboliquement tout était
sous contrôle
le dernier avion américain a décollé
embarqué comme dernier passager un
général américain qui est un clin d'oeil
aux russes qui avaient conclu leur
départ de kaboul par l'embarquement d'un
général je crois qu'à l'époque il
s'appelait le général grand moff le
désordre a été du côté des alliés de
l'otan qui n'ayant pas été prévenue des
détails de l'accord et du déroulement
des opérations
on tue énormément de problèmes pour le
ressortissant et bien sûr les afghans
travaillant pour eux il a fallu compter
sur la collaboration entre les talibans
et les qatari pour que les avions de ce
dernier pays puissent continuer à
évacuer les étrangers après la date
fatidique en tant que membre de l'otan
ayant participé pendant treize ans à la
guerre ayant eu des morts et des blessés
un pays comme la france ou l'allemagne
peut se poser des questions sur la
vision américaine de l'organisation
les pays européens
sont ils perçus comme des pourvoyeurs de
troupes de supplétifs au service des
états unis
ou bien des alliés et de véritables
partenaires dans une collaboration
sincère est ouverte il n'est pas normal
d'avoir été exclus et on comprend les
réactions mécontente des différents pays
d'europe dont certains ont été jusqu'à
faire démissionner leurs ministres de la
défense ont aussi questionné sur le rôle
et l'efficacité des services de
renseignement qui n'ont visiblement pas
récupéré toutes les informations utiles
pour faire face à la situation
les derniers événements annonçant la
création de locus et la prise de
contrôle du marché des sous marins
australiens par les états unis montrent
qu'une alliance entre anglo saxons pour
faire face à la chine avec la
participation probable du japon et
souhaité ne l'inde est en train de se
construire on est obligé de constater
que l'europe continentale et
principalement la france qui possède le
deuxième domaine maritime de la zone
indo pacifique en est exclu si on ajoute
que le congrès américain aurait chargé
avril hinse directrice du renseignement
national de travailler sur une extension
de l'accord five ait qui est plus connu
sous le nom de réseau échelon vous savez
qui regroupe les états unis le canada le
royaume uni l'australie et la
nouvelle-zélande
il voudrait l'étendre à l'allemagne au
japon et à l'inde on voit que le temps a
besoin d'être sérieusement redéfinie
car elle est à deux niveaux
ceux qui décident en commun et les
autres dont nous faisons partie
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
caroline galak terros présidente et
fondatrice du pôle de géostratégie
réaliste géo pragma le think tank duo
pragma à qui j'ai demandé de bien
vouloir réagir et compléter mon
interprétation
bonjour caroline bonjour à la caroline
pour commencer cette cet échange comment
de votre point de vue il faut analyser
la faire des sous marins australiens
vaste question
écoutez il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
vous avez déjà
évoqué un certain nombre de points oui
c'est la marque d'un déclassement
pour la france enfin c'est un signe
manifeste d'un d'une longue dégringolade
de notre posture à la fois stratégiques
politiques sur la scène internationale
et industriel oc et ce n'est pas
totalement accessoire
donc là nous avons eu en fait la preuve
que nous vivons avec les états unis
d'amérique mais aussi avec les anglais
qui ont été la cheville ouvrière de cet
accord et les australiens qui ont subi
eux aussi un chantage mais qui sont
évidemment rentrer dans le rang du trio
avec l'amérique et l'angleterre nous
nous vivons un amour à sens unique en
fait nous d'ailleurs nous concevons
les relations internationales comme des
relations d'amitié et alors que ça n'a
pas grand chose à voir avec le réel réel
c'est une re polarisation très agressive
sous la houlette américaine du monde
la désignation sans équivoque d'un emmy
effectivement la chine mais aussi la
russie même si vous l'avez évoqué le
découplage que tentent peut-être joe
biden
et qui arrive à mon avis un peu tard
mais qui a peut-être des chances aussi
ce serait bien qu'on ait l'occasion d'en
parler d'advenir entre la chine et la
russie
en dépit de ce découplage on est dans
une phase où il ya cette polarisation
agressive alors que le monde est de fait
police entrez donc c'est c'est déjà un
refus du réel et une remise en ordre de
bataille
autoritaire
et bien du pôle occidental qui est quand
même quand on regarde ces résultats
militaires
sur le terrain avec toutes ces guerres
d'ingérence depuis 30 ans qui est assez
mal en point finalement au plan des
résultats et entre temps la chine a
émergé et la russie s'est sauvé enfin a
réussi à survivre voilà comment je vois
les choses de l'orb helmand et alors là
dedans l'otan
l'otan vous l'avez rappelé elle a été
élargie pour en fait prendre soul est
occidentale et américaine
en fait une grande partie des forces de
l'ancien pacte de varsovie et surtout et
là c'est c'est très important à bien
comprendre et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne comprend pas on est dans un
déni complet l'otan va contre l'europe
en fait contre la possibilité d'une
europe puissance d'abord parce qu'il y à
tous les anciens satellites russes à
l'intérieur qui n'ont évidemment aucune
envie de se retrouver sous emprise ou
sous tutelle de moscou d'une manière ou
d'une autre donc ça ne peut pas avancer
deuxièmement
et bien l'otan est en fête alors elle
est inscrite comme l'outil militaires de
la défense européenne dans l'est dans
les traités européens en traité de
lisbonne donc quand on parle d'une
autonomie stratégique européenne c'est
très joli mais enfin c'est de l'ordre
des rêves
ça n'est juste pas possible pas
envisagée à moins de 2 de refaire tous
les traités européens
ce qui ce qui n'arrivera pas voilà et
deuxièmement on a parlé de l'allemagne
tout à l'heure
l'allemagne est désormais le point
d'appui
majeur des etats-unis en europe et la
france sa première victime collatérale
la première victime collatérale de cette
cet accord dont le projet nord stream ii
et la manière dont l'amérique a
finalement fait nécessité vertu n'est
qu'un exemple n'est qu'un exemple donc
nous on est quand même dans une posture
assez compliqué assez difficile je pense
que nous sommes à un point où nous
verrons manteau nous coûte extrêmement
cher notre déni de la réalité nous coûte
extrêmement cher notre crédulité notre
sincérité peut-être partiellement notre
naïveté sans doute vis-à-vis dé guerre
d'ingérence que nous menons comme
supplétifs américains ou parfois à notre
initiative d'ailleurs je pensais à la
libye et bien tout cela ne nous rapporte
ni crédit ni influence ni puissance
n'est rien et la sphère australienne la
a montré à quel niveau de considération
la france était de fait placer alors
juste pour pour terminer un peu ces
questions mais en même temps ça permet
d'avoir un balayage c'est qu'on très
complet le alors cette fameuse défense
européenne cette armée européenne enfin
qu'il qui portait par la france mais à
psion vous écoute on voit pas très bien
pas par la france part qu'elle est
portée en europe
oui c'est
tout à fait tout à fait non mais c'est à
dire il n'ya pas il ne peut pas y avoir
d'autonomie stratégique de l'europe pour
des raisons à la fois structurelle j'ai
parlé de l'élargissement c'est à dire
qu'en son sein
il y à tout un tas de pays qui n'en
veulent juste pas et même l'allemagne
l'allemagne est l'armé la plus intégrée
de l'alliance atlantique de l'otan donc
en fait nous avons la france nous nous
pourrions faire un certain nombre de
choses il faudrait déjà peut-être
reconsidérer notre position à
l'intérieur de l'alliance atlantique
est sans doute envisager de sortir de
son commandement intégré militaire
intégré parce qu'en fait on va être
entraîné dans cette polarisation est la
grande question c'est que soit on a le
courage de dire ça ne nous convient pas
la france est une puissance d' équilibre
une puissance intelligente est aussi une
puissance de l'inde au pacifique mais ne
conçoit pas forcément
l'hostilité comme seul mode de relation
avec les autres les acteurs
internationaux
soit on se laisse entraîner pour en
mettre c'est ce qu'on a déjà fait dans
un certain nombre de cas avec des
résultats malheureusement qui ne
correspondent pas à la sauvegarde de mon
point de vue et du point de vue de géo
magma en tout cas qui ne correspondent
pas du tout à la définition et à la
sauvegarde de nos intérêts vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure aussi des services
de renseignement et du fait qu'il
n'avait pas glané sur sur la sphère
australienne qui n'avait pas vu le coup
venir alors que c'est un coût qui a été
lancée je dirais presque au moment de la
conclusion de l'accord du siècle
qui a qui a eu un certain nombre
d'étapes bien sûr dont la dernière était
sans doute le sommet du g7 où pendant
qu'on discutait des conséquences du bric
site en fait le le traquenard se mettait
en place mais quand on dit les services
de renseignement
non pas vu mais ils n'ont pas vu comme
vous le savez fort bien parce qu'on ne
leur a pas demandé de regarder c'est à
dire nous avons aussi un problème de
conception du monde tant content qu'il
ya ce verrou mentale qui fait que l'on
considère que l'amérique et l'europe
c'est la même chose ça veut la même
chose ça doit aller dans le même sens ça
a les mêmes intérêts ce qui est un déni
de réalité évident
et bien on ne donne pas forcément des
orientations
aux services qu'ils conviennent donc
nous on les oriente vers la recherche
quand on les oriente quand on les
oriente il y aurait là aussi beaucoup à
dire mais on les oriente vers des des
axes de recherche qui vont vers les
ennemis ou adversaires socalled et et
pas évidemment vers nos alliés alors que
l' inverse fin août aux alliés ne se
prive de rien on l'a su il ya eu
suffisamment d'affaires pour en
témoigner et on a vu encore récemment
avec avec pegasus 1 c'était
on est bien d'accord merci caroline
merci pour ces ailes ou passionnant
merci
en 2006 a commencé à émerger l'idée
américaine d'une temps pouvant aller
partout et d'une collaboration basée sur
des contributeurs appelé à aider l'armée
américaine comme on l'a vu en irak le
président macron à vide il y a deux ans
que l'otan était en état de mort
cérébrale car elle ne jouait plus le
rôle pour lequel elle avait été conçue
d'ailleurs ça avait été un élément d'une
émission que nous avons fait les autres
pays européens
en commençant par les anciens pays de
l'est se sont posés des questions quand
le président trump voulait augmenter
sensiblement la charge de la défense sur
les pays européens pour lui pouvoir s'en
dégager la plupart de nos pays pensait
faussement que le président biden
reviendrait dans la position
traditionnelle des démocrates mais il
est clair que pour les états unis la
défense européenne n'est plus l'objectif
majeur de l'alliance ils veulent la
faire participer une politique
d'opposition à la chine
la question est donc maintenant
clairement posée l'otan est il
simplement un réservoir de troupes
européennes pour mettre en oeuvre la
politique américaine dans le monde
sachant que l'accès futur sera la zone
indo pacifique
à bientôt
[Musique]